hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at longnow
i'm coming to you live from the interval
to watch tonight's talk with craig
childs
he will also be joining us live from his
house in colorado to see this edited
version of his talk we recorded a few
weeks ago and we'll be answering
questions from you all selected by kevin
kelly
i'm super excited to have craig here
tonight giving a second talk in this
series craig is one of the greatest
adventurers and explorers that i know
where many people study the past craig
goes out and walks the paths of the
people he is studying
those paths have taken him to some of
the most inhospitable and beautiful
places on earth
tonight we will hear about one of those
journeys welcome craig
childs hi there
welcome to our home glad to have you
here
i am craig childs i'm a writer and a
traveler and i live here in western
colorado
to give you a sense of where we are back
behind me
behind this bookcase and the house are
the san juan mountains
and out ahead of me looking through that
door where it just
rained recently i'm looking about 50
miles and that's into utah there's a
a lone mountain range standing right
over there
looking south through the windows high
desert mesas
that are split open by a canyon coming
down here below the house
and like a lot of this landscape you can
see
part of it you see what's up on top most
of it is down inside
and you learn a place you learn how to
move through it you learn how to
navigate in these landscapes
and i look for signs on the ground of
who's been here what kind of stories are
being told by this
place this is something
that came from right around here this is
uh it's
probably a scraper on its way to
becoming
a a projectile point you can see the the
fluting marks
uh and and you can imagine somebody
using this to to scrape a hide
uh it's probably about four thousand
years old based on the sites around here
desert archaic culture and it came from
within
a hundred yards of the kitchen sink
when you look around you start to find
signs of people
everywhere this is a a nice little point
that came from
from right here near the house and you
can see the
the scallop marks where where somebody
sat and worked it
it was it was probably a longer point uh
maybe out to there and it broke and then
somebody
somebody worked worked the edges of it
got it back down to uh to make it usable
again
this is the tip
of likely an adoletal dart
and uh it's it's missing it's it's very
tip and the
the barb has broken off but you see that
uh
that fine work where you can imagine
somebody sitting down
and flaking this thing you can see their
hands where they
they used the tip of an antler and
wham knock these little pieces off you
can hear the sound
tick tick tick of somebody
making this thing
now that goes back 4 000 years ago like
i said
uh older is this thing
this is clovis technology from about 13
500 years ago and and this is
just a a beautiful point it's classic of
of the ice age um you can see the
the curved bottom this this kind of
rocket shape to it
and this is from from big big game
hunters
uh people were probably also using
little points like this back then
probably more often than these but these
are what really stand out
now this is not the original
this is a replica made by a master
flint knapper uh his name is greg
nunn and he lives
just over uh if i could move that
mountain range over i'd be able to see
him he lives about 60 miles from here
i'm interested in line of sight i'm
interested in horizons
and and what this place has been shaped
like for a long time
since humans have been here this place
tells stories and i want to go back into
those stories i want to go back to the
beginning
back into the ice age i want to know
what happened
between these horizons how people flow
across the land how many generations
have seen this place how many lives
have gone through here this is a map of
fluted points
basically clovis and its variations the
bright orange is where these projectiles
have been found
giving some sense of how people settled
the land around 13 000 years ago
they were freer to spread in the east
and then staggered through
mountain ranges plateaus and basins in
the west
if you looked closer you'd be able to
see trade routes and groups connected to
each other
now this is a map of novel coronavirus
infections
in april 2020 suggesting we have
something in common with ice age people
at least in the way we situate ourselves
and connect with others
these are maps of high technology for
their time
and high interaction sticking to rivers
and coastlines and the edges of mountain
ranges
we use the same passes the same gaps
we come to the same places
i brought up the shape of the land
because that's my guide for finding
people
from the late pleistocene i'm
triangulating
i'm looking for places on the ground
where you know people were here
they left tools here there's an
encampment
or they pass through you know there are
connections between places
or there was a mammoth here there was
there was a giant bison here
this is how i i can locate myself and
then i look at the horizon around me
because the ice age ended
10 000 eleven thousand years ago give or
take and that's not enough time for
these mountains to be different
mountains are where they are now where
they were
then the same rivers were flowing in the
ice age
so when you go to these places you're
seeing the
world as they saw it at least in the
bold elemental shapes
so here's how i do it i find a map that
shows the locations of the older sites
this is far west texas and the bottom of
new mexico
where my family's from i'm looking for
much older sites than that
and those are the red dots where clovis
points have been found
and it looks like there's a
concentration around what was an ice age
lake you drop into that place and you
see what it looks like
well it's windy
and it's dry these are the gypsum sands
of old shorelines
the lake bed itself is empty caves in
the mountains there in the distance have
produced bones of pleistocene megafauna
giant sloths and bears the size of
horses
they also turned up pollen and plant
parts so we can see what grew here
now it's hard scrabble chihuahuan desert
hardly a tree up there
then it was forested with pines and furs
and it
hung with canyon grapes you go with
people who are willing to do damn near
anything
which is maybe a prerequisite for
exploring a new
continent we set camp beneath the
surface of the lake
as if breathing underwater i was writing
a book about the ice age in north
america
it's called atlas of a lost world i'd
thought about going full
paleolithic for the book fireboards and
spears
but as you can see i was having enough
trouble just keeping my tent from
blowing away
the artifacts we found were of a certain
age
like this big block of styrofoam that
had been blowing around in the desert
for so long it was bristled with
sticks that had been stabbed all over it
oh yeah come on
time out there was hard to keep a hold
of
the white sands looked like snow yet
middle of the day
felt like this i think the edges of time
can be blurred and sometimes
you pass right through i'm interested in
the differences between
then and now what ties us together
in the distance we were hearing the
bombing range
atmospheric sounds of concussions far
away
a friend on the trip had been a bomb
defuser for the army working in baghdad
and he could identify what kind of
weapons we were hearing
meanwhile i'd been looking at the kinds
of projectiles people left from their
time
fluted clovis points circa 13
hundred years ago i went into
collections
and i studied their strike marks which
you start to read like
languages in themselves i was also
looking for
non-human remains which is most of what
was happening in north america
when the first people were here this is
a skull of arctotus the short-faced bear
an american giant if you're trying to
understand
these animals i think you need to try
them on you need to look
at this from i am a human and this is a
giant bear
what could our relationship have been
like
down in the basement of the smithsonian
in dc
this is a piece of dung from a giant
sloth that lived in the dry caves of the
grand canyon
was looking at cabinets full of this
stuff pulling out these these boluses
which
which are completely dry they they feel
like you're you're holding paper mache
and you can see the chewed up seeds and
and
grasses and stems and you can imagine
this
the size of this animal i was looking at
the collection with
the museum's director kirk johnson and
we found this glyptodont skeleton back
against a wall
basically it's a one-ton armadillo that
lived in the south
new mexico to florida and this is an
interesting one we pulled out of a
drawer
can you tell what it is it is part of
the lower
jaw and incisors of a pleistocene beaver
it would have stood six feet tall on its
hind legs
so why such big animals it's pretty
simple
temperatures were colder and mammals
needed to hold in their heat
this is a constant through the
paleontological record
cold ages have big animals warm ages
like the one we're in now have small
ones
and the big animals tend to leave more
signs
these are colombian mammoth trackways on
a barren lake bed
down in southern new mexico around where
those clovis points showed up
these were the largest proboscideans on
earth tusks were
13 feet long and they were encountered
by people
human tracks left in their tracks spear
points found
lodged in their bones when they walked
along the shore of this lake
their weight compressed each print and
now the wind blows around them the
sediment that was packed harder stays in
place a little longer
so these aren't fossils per se they're
just prints they're just
sediment they're animal prints and with
a full trackway you can see the mammoth
actually walking
right left right left right left
we made long forays across these lake
beds
and i wasn't really expecting to find
anything i was just there to see the
weather rolling across
us these zinc colored dust devils that
would stir
up but we did eventually find
what looked like seven prints of uh
colombian mammoth these are
two of the stronger looking prints and
they could have just been blotches on
the ground some kind of mineralization
until you see the walking pattern
there was a mammoth here in this place
it moved through this space it had a
shape in the air
and i walked next to it looking at each
step imagining its tusks swaying
back and forth imagining its shape right
here in this place
i was talking with a navajo singer in
northern arizona
and this was years ago i was traveling
through the area with my friend
and we were looking for permission so he
went to his hogan
and and we brought groceries and sacks a
flower he invited us in
and we sat and talked for a while uh
translating through his
his uh his adult grandson and
and the singer asked if
if i had any questions i could ask
anything i wanted
and i said how did your people come to
be
in this place how did the dna arrive in
northern arizona
and he said we came from the ground
and i knew this this story from navajo
cosmology that that the people emerged
from
underground and that's how they arrived
in this
in this desert um and and so i pressed
him on
it and he said no there there was there
was no migration we didn't arrive from
somewhere else we came from the ground
and i think i was being tone deaf at
this point but i
i was trying to get to another point i
was saying well the
the dna language your language is here
in arizona and it's also
in the arctic in the yukon territory in
alaska and it's also in siberia so
there's this
arc out of asia into the americas
and he said no we came
from the ground and i looked down
at the red moen copy hard pack
underneath his hogan
and i thought they came from the ground
of course this is part of so many of the
stories
that come out of north america out of
the native american tradition
of going from one world to the next
arriving in a new world
for the navajo there are the monster
slayer stories where
two twins are sent out to uh
to kill the um the monsters that
occupied the world
and make it safe for people for the
klinkit
and haida of the far northwest coast
the first people arrived in a clam shell
that was was sealed closed and it washed
up
on a beach and trickster god raven
showed up and opened up the clamshell
and let the first people out
for the hopi the arrival into this world
was uh the last world was flooding and
they crawled through a hole which turned
out to be a hole in the ground
into this world and the water rose and
sent them up to here
there are so many stories about arrival
and transformation
that i i think it must have been a big
thing getting here
threading the eye of a needle a journey
was involved
a migration not from some other land or
continent
but from the ground from another world
which to me means a long
long time ago an arrival that people are
still
talking about and it was probably
different for everyone
if you were approaching during the late
pleistocene the only land connection was
along the arctic circle
which would have led into a death trap a
single glacier the size of antarctica
sitting on the brow of north america one
way or another you were going to have to
deal with this sort of environment
from alaska onward it was 2 000 miles of
snow and ice before you'd touch ground
somewhere in montana or the dakotas
which is why i loaded up gear
with a group and headed for the harding
ice field in south central alaska
i wanted to see what they saw
twenty thousand years ago we were hardly
different
anatomically almost indistinct from
modern humans
drop one in a crowd of us and you'd
never pick them out
like us i think they would have stood on
a high point at the end
of a long day and looked across rock and
ice
with a combination of dread and wonder
everything was bigger in the ice age
their ice sheet was almost 6 million
square miles
ours was 700
but i think we would have done and seen
some of the same things
scouting up into passes and then pausing
at the last life
before this great white emptiness ahead
of us
in the pleistocene i think i would have
snared and eaten those tarmagan
people's diets were diverse more
foragers and scavengers than
hunter-gatherers
single encampments with salmon seaweed
and mastodon
and all sorts of roots and seeds
we ate clif bars and meals in foil
packages
we saw mountains swallowed blazing white
to the horizon riddled with dangerous
crevasses and wide open planes
and our camps were a study of humans in
elemental spaces
what we do how we act in different
conditions
the only notable difference beside our
technology is cranial size
humans twenty thousand years ago had
brains five percent larger than ours
maybe they had a heightened sense of awe
or whatever it was that drew them
farther and farther more starts going
through your mind when you're out here
everything is a sign the only indication
of life was something like this
crushed rodent bones coughed up by a
bird on a high point
a rock ridge sticking up through the ice
these exposed ridges and summits are
called
noon attacks this is an important
feature to know in the ice age
a noon attack is a landform swallowed
almost completely by the ice
with only a tip sticking through there
are these enchanting landforms these
ragged castles sitting out on the plain
and below thousands of feet of mountain
under the ice people could have used
these as stepping stones
hopping down the rockies and the coastal
ranges
we went up on them because it only
seemed natural
this is how you make your map you climb
you get a vantage
you see a head reaching the top is like
setting a compass point on the saddle of
this noon attack
i found a feather it had melted into the
snow
and nearby i found the bird's tracks a
raven
it landed up here and walked to the edge
of a cornice
i could see where it came from and where
it was going
maybe landing up here to rest its wings
and where it flew from the cornice i
could see the map that spread below it
i believe animals had a lot to do with
moving humans into this continent
people would have come down the kelp
beds of the coast and skinned boats
fishing and hunting the rich waters and
followed birds across the ice
you get swept up in migrations and they
pull you along
where did these animals take the first
people
florida panhandle was this a river about
as far as you can get from the bering
land bridge without falling off of north
america
completely ice free down here the place
was rich with megafauna remains
right out there in the river where we're
looking right now you can see out in the
middle
two guys in the 1980s found a giant ice
age bison skull bison antiquis
seven feet tall at the hump and i
imagine them lifting it out of the
riverbed
one on each bony remnant of a horn
one of the things they noticed right
away was a human weapon
broken off in its forehead scientists
looked at it and determined the point
made of local swani chert had been
embedded while the bone was still
fresh and it didn't penetrate the brain
case so it was not a killing blow
you have to wonder what this story was
who threw this projectile
and what happened next and you have to
wonder
what else they were encountering
i walk around my neighborhood thinking
of mountain lions
and bears and it raises the hairs on the
back of my neck
imagine walking around thinking of
this predator
this is a saber-toothed cat and uh
and this is uh this is one of the
animals that
humans were encountering if you open the
jaw here that's that's about how far
it would have opened you can feel the uh
the sabers and they are bladed
on both sides so they're designed to
get into something and tear back and
forth they're designed to
to rip open anything this is just
carnage
and not all the big cats of the ice age
were like this
uh the scimitar cat that was a little
bit smaller probably about 400 pounds
had more serrated like a like a steak
knife
little teeth along the the incisors
and that was designed to to cut
open and then peel back big slabs of
flesh
there was also a a 700 pound jaguar
called an american lion so you had these
these big animals out there this was the
world
people were living in and florida had
the highest concentration of
direwolves and saber-toothed cats in the
americas
so this was this was something that
people would have encountered back then
so you can imagine what was on my mind
when i was traveling the back woods
rivers south of tallahassee
i was thinking of mastodon there are
forms hulking back in the trees
and a southern subspecies of the giant
bear arctotus
and of course big cats numerous species
walking through the shadows
things have changed a bit these rivers
existed at the time
but they flowed through a very different
landscape in the ice age
florida was more savannah the american
kenya
not as much water but heavy with protein
researchers have found entire macedon
and bison skeletons laid out on river
bottoms around here
like x-rays i joined a couple friends
who were on their honeymoon crossing
parts of florida by boat
when they passed through the wasissa
ocilla and econfina rivers
which is the heart of human occupation
in florida going back
at least 15 000 years i jumped on
we set camps in pine palm woods
nights clicking and humming with insects
or out on the marshy flats along the
gulf coast
which during the ice age when sea levels
were lower this was still 200 miles from
the coast
florida was twice the size of what it is
now
and i have to say this was my first time
seeing this part of the country really
my first time in florida
alligators unfurling from shore plunging
in and disappearing beneath you
armadillos and grunting feral pigs
snakes in the trees
i don't know who thought of that snakes
in the trees that's just a terrible idea
when you happen to bump your kayak
alongside a sunning snake and you don't
know the species if it's venomous or not
you memorize its patterns the tones of
its eyes
starting to learn who lives here because
really these are the people
and you are the one passing through i'm
trying to understand what it's like to
be in a place for
for the first time looking at these
animals with
new eyes and looking at the landscape
with new eyes this
this was not a kind of place i'm used to
rivers appeared and disappeared
going under and rising back to the
surface and these sinkholes
where the rivers go back in or where
they come out is where most of the
evidence comes from
we found this in the woods water welling
up from below
and down inside there'll be artifacts
and bones divers have excavated these
holes
finding entire stomach contents of a
mastodon
parts of every animal that lived here
innumerable artifacts from the ice age
we cannonballed into this particular one
and i remember the current
tugging at my feet and how dark it was
when i looked down
shadows falling into shadows
one researcher described diving in one
of these holes with another excavator
and pulling a long ivory shaft out of a
crack
part of a throwing weapon and he was so
excited that he was shouting over his
regulator
and another diver told me about drifting
down to the bottom with a weight belt
and it's being completely black down
there flicking on a thousand watt
light and the megafauna bones were all
around him glowing
like gold i think of these
as emergence places spots on the land
where the ice age pokes
up through this is the galt site in
central texas
and it has human artifacts going back 25
000 years
i walked down into this pit and i was
going layer by layer
going down through time and the lower i
got
the more the ground of the the trenches
became wet
and there were uh generators going and
and hoses pumping water back out because
this was cut down below the water table
down to where people left artifacts
25 000 years ago if the pump stopped
running this would just fill up
like a swimming pool and of course i'm
thinking about the old stories down here
about
the old dna man who told me that
the people came from the ground so many
of those original stories are about this
watery underworld
and i thought is this the place they're
talking about is this one of the
emergence sites
we got into the bags of of artifacts
and uh and found the oldest one there
the last artifacts that have been picked
up
this is a core left behind from
manufacture
but you hold it and you think at the
time i was there they were only down to
the 15
000 year lair and i and i was thinking
this was
touched by somebody 15 000 years ago
this thing felt like a time machine
people arrived in this continent and
then
went everywhere and this rock was still
wet
as if from birth this is the
oldest documented rock art in north
america it's 14
800 years old found in the nevada desert
and nearby is the blackrock desert
which at the end of the ice age
contained the largest freshwater lake on
the continent
and its edges were dotted with
encampments i walked for several days
along
these old lake terraces where i found
these ancient encampments with weapons
and
tools places where people had sat and
flaked along the edge of this
ancient lake it must have been just an
incredible place to live in the late
pleistocene
the largest mammoth found in north
america was found down there
on those those old shorelines and i'd
looked down into this barren and
waterless place
i could see what they saw
i could see the water filling in the
spaces
in the distance night by night we saw a
burning man
growing out there on the blackrock
desert
what's happening out there craig i don't
know there seems to be some kind of
drone-like madness
giant sculptures out in the middle of
the desert
a lot of music looks like a
ton of people like two miles wide
that's going to be a crazy spot at the
end of the ice age
people started gathering in noticeable
numbers the first
big sites this is a map of the bull
brook site in eastern massachusetts
one of the earliest large gathering
places on the continent around 11 000
years ago
based on the artifacts it looks less
like a village
and more like an organized seasonal
gathering from hundreds of miles in all
directions
the individual rocks found there could
be traced back so you could tell where
people were coming from to bring their
rocks
each point on this map is a different
encampment
where it appears people were working on
isolated tasks
some making projectiles some camps for
scrapers and blades
some camps using tools for cutting and
sewing and hide production
the lay of the site is roughly circular
or
semi-circular and it's gathered around a
central focus
this is the layout of burning man
same pattern it's how people come
together
all facing inward toward the center
these large gatherings appear to have
been a reaction to a major climatic
event
called the younger driest climate
anomaly
i'd say this was the formative moment of
the ice age
so let me set the stage for this last
location right before all those
big gatherings started happening 20
000 years ago was the last glacial
maximum the coldest point in the ice age
the ice out to its farthest extent
for several thousand years after that
the ice age was stepping back
warming up the glaciers were melting
and that meant fresh water was coming
off huge
rivers and floods so this was a powerful
time
i talked to paleo archaeologists who say
if they could get in a time machine
this is where they'd go this warming
period 14 000 years ago 13 000 years ago
the
the rise of clovis and then suddenly
it changed 12 800 years ago
the ice age engine turned back on
within a decade conditions went back to
20 000 years ago
we were now again in the cold period the
ice started expanding
permafrost started going back into the
ground and extinctions
radiated out across the continent this
cold
lasted for a thousand years let me take
you to that place
that puts me here over in the corner of
lake superior in the deepest freeze
since the 1970s
this is a nasa image of that week
late january 2014 it looked like the ice
age was coming back which is never
really
out of the question the event is known
as a polar vortex
super chilled air that usually
circulates over the pole
pours down the continent freezing
everything in its path
it's caused from actually from heating
events elsewhere on the planet
that bubble up into the atmosphere and
hit the arctic air and push it out
just throwing off the systems the result
was a deep freeze in the upper midwest
where even ice was growing on ice
temperatures were to negative 50. by the
time i got there on the tail of the
vortex they were up to
30 below this was my proxy for the
younger dryas
a sudden change for the cold on a much
smaller scale but something that i could
i could feel myself
i loaded up a toboggan with gear
harnessed the thing to myself and
marched across frozen lake superior
in places the snow blew out and i could
see
what was beneath me the younger dryas
possibly originated from a reversal of
ocean currents
or fallout from a comet impact some
believe
megafauna overkill from human hunting
changed the biotic structure
of north america enough to restart the
ice age
it was probably all of the above because
this is how our planet works
the clockwork just sometimes flies apart
when it hit in the warmest part of the
ice age settlements
changed locations new trade routes
appeared new kinds of tools and
technologies
community structures became visible
trade centers seasonal gatherings
no more clovis points clovis was done
weapons became smaller
more versatile not just mammoth stabbers
it was a wide scale adaptation a kind of
sea
change i don't know if my experience had
anything in common with theirs but my
first night on the lake
was kind of awful this was my camp
no tent a bivvy on the snow and a
sleeping bag that felt like crawling
into a bear
and this is me in the morning grouchy
and swollen from rolling around all
night i didn't sleep at all
trying to keep off the frostbite and the
ice was
booming and thundering beneath me all
night long
which was magical and terrifying and
after a while
enough i had to chisel out the zippers
just to get out of my bag in the morning
and to get out of my bivy it took me
about an hour
i was supposed to do this for three
nights walking across the bay with a
toboggan
but forget that i loaded up
and headed for sure thinking adapt to
your environment
a few days earlier with some students
from northland college
in ashland wisconsin i'd helped build a
snow shelter on shore
it was a quincy a spacious little den
with a hole for an entrance
and the hole was placed so it's below
the floor inside
you push your gear ahead of you and you
enter
this space and the hole keeps the cold
air
from from rushing in and allows the warm
air to collect inside and
the students who had who'd built this
thing they left tea candles
and a thermometer so i lit them up
i could spread my gear out a little and
relax thinking
how many people have done this in human
history sheltered against the severity
outside
waiting to emerge from my body heat and
the candles
i got the temperature from negative 27
up to
negative 10 which actually felt balmy i
unzipped for the first time in
like a day and a half pulled off my big
hat off my gloves
and i could breathe again
it was quiet in there no sound from
outside
no reference point you'd think it was
claustrophobic but
it was sheltering it felt safe like
being in a womb
maybe you can't help replaying the old
stories i mean they're written into the
place
the source where people came from the
underworld
when that candle went out the shelter
fell
into complete darkness no sense of
direction
so silent maybe this is what the
beginning
feels like dark and ready
it was the softest sleep i think i've
ever had
no dreams just clean
here at the start of an age
thank you for listening
thank you craig that was fantastic uh
we're gonna be pulling craig's feet in
from where he's sheltering in place in
colorado
welcome great to see you good to see you
xander
that was a great tour um i love
that the arc of it and uh you know going
all the way to florida from
basically siberia and getting a sense of
how people
moved across the continent over the last
10 to 20
000 years and actually it brings up one
of the first questions that kevin kelly
had is
um what's your opinion of some of these
some of these new evidence of people
coming in
much earlier than that do you are you a
subscriber to the earlier
americans yeah i think theory i i i
think they go back
much earlier i i think as archaeology
keeps looking especially along
shorelines
underwater archaeology the the dates are
going to keep going back
because uh you know right now
they're they're hovering around 20 000
years but they're
they're little inklings of of forty
thousand fifty thousand out there
um and and even older so i think those
states will
keep going back because people
have always been coming to this place
and probably some of them
didn't didn't make it they they maybe
left tools but no
genetic signature that they died off
so i i think the story is is complicated
it's not just
one one wave of people it is tens of
thousands of years of people i mean i
love this idea that you bring up of
emergence places is that a
did you coin that term is this uh is
this an archaeological term
no i think it's more uh it's definitely
it comes from in in my world in the in
the southwest where
where the stories are are hopi
navajo danae stories uh about um
emergence points there are places on the
map where
where people are said to have come into
this world
and and you know i've i've as a science
writer i've taken some flack for writing
about this
because you know i've had people come
back and go you cannot tell me that
people crawled out of the ground that
just did not happen and
i'm saying well you know stories are a
little bit more
transparent uh than the black and white
ideas of of uh you know archaeological
evidence only i think that they're
on along with archaeological evidence
there has to be
cultural evidence uh human story
evidence
and and that's where emergency points
come in there at least in the southwest
they're they're all over the place
you know you'll be you'll be sitting at
a at a butte out in the desert and
talking to somebody about this and
they'll say oh yeah that's that's one of
our emergence points right there and go
oh well
another one people this is
this is how this works people came from
another world in
into this one so it's it's a term
i don't think i've coined it uh but it
it fits
for me to look at archaeological sites
and go oh
another emergence point right
that's i love the term um kevin kelly
also asks um
why weren't there civilization scale
settlements of native americans in
california
and sacramento river valleys like we see
in the amazon and mississippi
rivers or were they and that we just
don't have the kind of evidence of them
yeah that's that's a good question i
what i've understood from coastal
california is that uh
it was it was such a uh
such an abundant place that there was no
need to
to go on go into the large public
architecture scale
and and maybe it's it's just where
people historically settled
i think the mississippi river the whole
all the all the mound building that went
down down the tributaries
down to the gulf the some of the oldest
mounds
in the americas are found down there uh
i think when something started 5 000
years ago it kept going where
i i don't see that as much on the
california coast i see it more
nomadic um uh more
uh you know it's not a place where
where pyramids popped up it wasn't it
wasn't like south america
and south america has such a different
history than north america
um the you can't even compare the two
north america seems almost
more staid more simple whereas south
america
in the ice age was as far as people
could have gotten on the planet to find
a habitable
habitable place so that has a whole
different
story and where large-scale civilization
popped up um
i think is it's where people were the
longest where
agriculture uh really had a had a
foothold which maybe wasn't so much on
the coast of california because
you had abundance you didn't have to
have surplus in
in corn the way that uh the way that you
did in the southwest or in the southeast
yeah i've always wondered why um
california seems to be one of the few
places on earth
where uh native early cultures
didn't value gold also because clearly
when the first
you know white people arrived in the
sacramento valley they picked up nuggets
the size of their fists out of the river
whereas in central and south america and
even mexico
those cultures valued gold and
everywhere else in the world do you have
any
sense of why is it the dramatic nature
or
yeah i think heavy metals aren't good
they may have noticed that and and also
uh
the the trade routes were pretty
extensive into the southwest and
southeast
uh there were live tropical macaws
within the last thousand years being uh
appearing up in northern new mexico and
turquoise
heading south and and shell being
moved around for ornamentation uh so
southwest and southeast were were part
of some pretty significant
trade routes going into uh into
central america and granted this is this
is well after the ice age
uh what you'd call pre-columbian
but the in the ice age i think people
were covering the same distances
um no sign of them using gold
uh but they were using uh red ochre that
was a major
uh stone for them and actually for for
everybody worldwide
it's it's the ceremonial mineral for for
humanity shows up in
in a lot of the earliest sites and there
were actually
red ochre mines um in
in the northeast and and in the
southwest so
people 10 10 15 000 years ago 10 000
years ago were
were mining uh and and moving red ochre
along these trade routes
nice we're gonna bring in stuart brand
he has some questions
welcome stuart hey craig how are you
hi stuart hi good to see you good to see
you thanks for doing this
certainly um i've got a question about
and they're in the southwest
uh you're talking about navajo and
apache arrived at a certain point
out of the ground or from siberia and
uh when they got there they were
encountering people who had been there
for a while the various
pueblo tribes and um
[Music]
so their interaction was not always
friendly
uh it's not even friendly sometimes now
i'm curious what you figured out as
these various waves of humans arrived
in north america uh from eurasia
how do they deal with each other maybe
along the way
or maybe later arrivals dealing with
earlier rivals or what's your sense of
the nature of interaction of those
peoples that's that's a good question i
i how i imagine the interaction
is probably different than it actually
was uh because i
i'm imagining some of the the earliest
people
just encountering other humans is is
necessary for survival you couldn't have
been a a small group you couldn't have
been
10 20 or even 30 people and genetically
survive
so you needed other people you needed
over thousands of years you had to have
a better genetic pool than just a small
group
um but then at the same time there's
plenty of evidence
for human remains with weapons in them
kennewick man uh had a uh
had a spear point or a projectile stone
projectile
embedded in his hip uh and the bone had
grown over it so there's there's
ample evidence that that it wasn't that
much different people
were killing each other like people
always do
but at the same time you
see artifacts mixing
uh clovis the clovis points of
13 000 years ago weren't the only points
being made
on the continent there were also on the
west side uh
california and the inner mountain ranges
there was a kind of projectile called a
stemmed point
and it was totally different from clovis
so you can see
two at least two major groups occupying
the continent
and these weapons are mixing and
some of the styles are being picked up
by different people and
you know you had mentioned uh navajo and
hopi
navajo coming in later than the hopi uh
and and yeah there was there was
probably conflict
um but also you look at the
evolution of navajo culture and it has a
lot of
of pueblo in it and a lot of
ceremonialism that comes from
pueblo sources so people
are are probably bumping heads
throwing adele darts at each other uh
but also studying each other uh
picking up languages and customs i i
think the
the ice age was was a big cultural mix i
think there were people who were still
connected to siberia
and people who were who had been here
already for tens of thousands of years
uh there's evidence of of paleolithic
europeans arriving
on the northeast coast and they probably
would have arrived and found people
already here and i wonder what was that
exchange like
you know people from totally different
linguistic and technological backgrounds
meeting i and i hard to tell what it was
like on the ground in the moment
but in the long run you see styles
mixing
and becoming something new
i i realized i have i used to spend time
not nearly as much as you have with some
of the southwestern tribes
and um i'm sort of thinking through
the the pueblos were basically forts
they're almost like cattle hayak one of
the first
cities in the world that you know he had
no doors or windows on the outside
you got into them with ladders and you
got down into the rooms in them
via ladders in the in the earliest times
and it is now occurring to me that i
suspect
that the various pueblo tribes uh
zuni and the hopi and and and
were somewhat predating on each other
maybe on their corn fields and whatnot
and so they had those forts i'm now
guessing
probably completely wrong but let me try
it with you
before the apaches and navajos showed up
and then when the apaches in navajos
showed up
they weren't worked out their own form
of
raiding and whatnot but they themselves
never built forts
the hogans are not at all fort like
they're just a
really intelligent way to get out of the
weather um
do you have any ideas on that well i
think
the the pueblo people were there
much longer and they're more
agricultural
um you know settle in a place and they
had
you know very or they still they
continue to have very
tight social networks um that
that uh that are based in that place uh
like the we were talking earlier about
this this notion of
of um of emergence points there's also
uh a notion of the center place
which is where you've migrated to after
thousands of years the
the hopi mesas akama zuni
and and this is based on thousands of
years of
of architecture and and uh
and public architecture big you know
kivas
plazas um and
whereas the the athabascan influence
the people who came down from the north
they
uh they were more hunter-gatherer more
nomadic more mobile so they picked up
pieces of of pueblo life
but building building a uh
a pueblo on the top of a mesa that's
going to stand there for
thousands of years and it's going to be
occupied for thousands of years
that wasn't so much part of the the uh
the hunter-gatherer way
right thank you stewart thank you
um we have a question from steve cisney
from
youtube um did you also look at previous
ice ages
and if so are there clues from that that
have helped you
understand the most recent one
yeah i've looked at um uh
i guess two and a half million years of
ice ages and how they came and went
and and i guess one
i my understanding of these ice ages is
more uh
looking at the the animals that were
there i i worked for
for years on a pleistocene dig in
southern colorado where
down inside of a cave uh
you could see the stratigraphy of i
think we had
17 ice ages that we were going through
so going back uh
uh 300 000 years 350 000 years and you
could see
you know here's the here's the warm
period all the animals are small the
bones are small and then here's the cold
period
which is much longer and much larger
animals and
and so i'm watching that that cycle of
big to small but i'm also watching how
um how the megafauna survives
from one ice age to the next because
mammoths
basically kept living through each ice
age this is the only time
that they didn't make it which i think
has a lot to do with humans being on the
ground
uh but they would go up into relic
ecosystems up in the rockies and they
would wait out
10 000 years of of interglacial
and then when the next ice age would
come they would spread back down into
the land so
so i i see this rhythm
of ice age interglacial ice age
and and uh when when humans enter the
scene
that's where i see this pattern change
you know the the big animals go extinct
for the first time
they almost all went extinct in north
america so
i think it is important to look beyond
just this one
late pleistocene moment into
into the much longer moments of these
glaciers coming and
going over over hundreds of thousands of
years
i love this idea of that the warming
climate brings
smaller animals um and then you can
track it by the tool usage
um of those times and this and you know
it's also interesting that now we have
you know the largest
mammal to ever have lived in the earth
is the blue blue whale but i guess that
the oceans are tracking on
slightly different cycles right right
there you don't uh
you're not as attached to uh to these
smaller changes i mean
definitely whales are attached to to
changes that are going on
but but terrestrial changes are a whole
different story uh
that that is an interesting notion that
we do have the largest animal
in in largest mammal in earth's history
i think it's the largest animal in in
earth's history and
and it's but it came from the
pleistocene
uh it's it dates back before it
it's just one that's still around and
maybe it's been able to evade us in ways
that mammoths
weren't able to yeah they were harder to
hurt off cliffs
right in mass in the pacific with the
boat technology
peter laden from the youtube stream asks
is there any way to
calculate how many people were in north
america like in these periods and 10 000
years ago 20 000 years ago
no
[Laughter]
very few human remains have have
survived
um there's a handful of of actual
people actual human bones that have come
out of the ice age it is it's just
long enough ago that that uh that
people that remains just
have not have not survived interestingly
it's
mostly children that have been found
and in burial contexts which which
implies
that uh children were cared for in death
whereas
adults maybe they were cared for in a
different way that they didn't show up
but that's a great question because
it could have been a lot of people you
know it could have been a million people
it could have been 50 000 people
uh all spread out across the continent
enough to keep the gene pool
going strong uh and setting the
foundation for
for native america um but
telling how many people is is really
hard
and even even going back uh a thousand
years into the southwest where
archaeology is just
all over the place it's hard to tell you
know was
was this household
the you know the seven people who lived
here
all represented by this one place or
were they represented by these
20 different locations where they may
have moved seasonally
so it's very hard to to get a population
interesting yeah i remember standing at
the precipice looking over choco canyon
and kind of getting
a sense of clearly there's there was you
know this massive culture that's not
here anymore
um but yeah what those numbers are is
i guess impossible yeah and you look at
choco and you kind of spread
out from there and realize there are
chocos everywhere they're
the the choco and great houses just keep
going and
you realize that oh there were people
all over this place
and now much more concentrated the
populations
now in the four corners are smaller
arguably smaller than they were a
thousand years ago
and in the yucatan as well oh yeah yeah
this this was a heavily populated
continent one way or another
and i think even going back into the ice
age i think uh
uh people were everywhere yeah with the
clock site in west texas not far from
where you talked about
um the well there was a brush fire there
and all of a sudden you could see
the evidence of settlements and at every
drainage that no longer is a
is a creek but must have been then and
it's just wild to think of how many more
people that land supported
yeah and people moving across it people
covering
significant distances where
where they were carrying stone tools in
the ice age
400 500 miles sometimes a thousand or
more
and so is it how many people were along
that route
or were they just there were these
periods of emptiness you know 100
200 miles of of nothing no other human
contact i really wonder
i i would love to see what it was like
back then
yeah indeed um well i want to point out
um before i
ask my last question that uh i believe
we posted to all the streams a
a link that allows you to order your
book uh about this
uh from and other books uh of yours that
i would highly recommend are some of my
favorite adventure stories
um thank you uh from local book sellers
um
and um kevin kelly is gonna give us our
last question
to close out tonight um how is your
research into ice age humanity change
your concepts
of what humans will seek in the next
thousand years
ah that's a that's a good question uh
because i
you know i look at people arriving in
north america and i think
um you know in one way i think okay this
is the the native american foundation
this this went to a a certain group of
people
but i also look at it and go okay this
is human
um let's look back and see what humans
did and and i
especially look at the clovis period and
it was a time of incredible climatic
change
sea levels rising in ways that uh that
we can't conceive of right now
i i mean it was it was a pretty dramatic
environmental change at the end of the
ice age and
and uh their reaction to it seems to
have been make
bigger weapons kill larger animals
and that's when you see a lot of the
major megafauna kills
is right in that time period and i
wonder
i look at us and i go okay is that
something that we're doing
that that we're experiencing a lot of
social change
climate change uh over over a hundred
years
and we build the biggest weapon we can
build uh we
we build up a nuclear arsenal is this
is this how humans do it when things get
hard when things
get thrown in our faces environmental
changes that are extraordinary do we
do we say we are actually huge and we
will dominate and i worry about that
because i i go okay well what does that
mean
with our scale of civilization dominance
i mean
we're already dominating so much
but then what came after you know that
younger dryas period when things got
cold is
people broke into smaller groups they
were still connected
but they changed they adapted no more
giant clovis points
they they became the foundation of
native america and that's
that's where i look at our maybe not
where we want
to head but where we naturally head is
is we use ourselves up and then we fall
back and go okay
how do how do we do this how do we adapt
what what do we make out of ourselves
next which i think that question
was probably being asked in clovis time
before
everything changed i think the questions
we're asking now
are the ones that are going to make the
future a thousand years from now
thank you so much this is fantastic and
i can't wait to
read about your next adventure thank you
thank you for having me here
absolutely take care
good night everybody thank you for
joining us
[Music]